this morning the State State Department
rather is calling on North Korea to
quote refrain from provocations North
Korea fired another ballistic missile
yesterday
just hours after agreeing to resume
stalled nuclear talks with the u.s.
South Korean officials confirm the
missile was launched on the coast of
Wonsan that's east of the North Korean
capital of Pyongyang it flew for about
280 miles and reportedly landed in the
Sea of Japan Ramey and Senseo is
following this story from Hong Kong so
rainy how could this affect the nuclear
talks good morning Gail well experts say
that this really is North Korea's way of
ramping up pressure against the United
States ahead of those talks this
Saturday
they say this is also a calculated show
of strength by the rogue nation as it
attempts to project its growing military
might now US officials tell CBS News
that this was a land-based test of a
mid-range ballistic missile that can be
launched from a submarine this is a
significant escalation of course from
the short-range missiles North Korea has
tested so far this year and authorities
are especially concerned about this type
of weapon because it is much harder to
detect in advance now this is the ninth
time North Korea has tested weapons ever
since late July nuclear talks between
the u.s. and North Korea have so far
stalled since the Vietnam summit between
President Trump and North Korean leader
Kim jong-un in February
failed to produce a deal now the White
House says it is monitoring the
situation closely and is also discussing
with US allies in the region but looking
ahead to Saturday not sure yet on how
it'll impact those negotiations
Tony Ramiro Senseo for us in Hong Kong
ramie thank you very much